people don't actually understand that your poor sleeping habits
affect your relationship with your partner
many issues in relationships are directly related to sleep
couples aren't getting good quality sleep
which directly leads to arguments and other issues
so many issues in relationships are directly related to sleep
issues, we all should understand that we need sleep to properly function.
in some studies,
people have said that sleep deprivation is probably one of the worst
forms of punishment
so we all should agree that sleep is important right?
not only is it important,
but it's also important to get good quality sleep
Do you get good sleep? Well
the first step is understanding your basic sleep cycles
and the most important stages
which are three and four
okay all stages are important
but stage 3 is when you get deep sleep
is basically when your body repairs itself, and builds tissue, bone,
muscle, all very vital okay
age 4 is dream sleep
this is when your brain dreams,
processes information,
and stores memories.
If you're not getting good quality sleep
your body isn't able to repair itself,
you're not able to process information,
store your memories,
If you’re not getting good sleep
this is gonna affect your mood,
your physical,
mental health,
and then that's gonna affect your relationship.
Sleep is such a critical pillar of health
that's probably why you see so many couples not sharing the same bed
your schedule or routine doesn't align with theirs
so it's important to find what works for you
at the end of the day
if you're not getting good quality sleep
that's gonna directly affect your relationship, and
love for each other
so make sure you're getting good!
Quality sleep